Speaker 1: . You know, there are such things
as coincidences. There really are. I've had
coincidences where, you know, I'm on a flight
and I happen to be sitting next to Alex Jones
lawyer just after Alex Jones attacks me.
Speaker 3: That is a frickin predator, right?
Speaker 1: Okay. Like that's a coincidence. I
don't believe that there's any larger message
for me to glean from being sat on a plane next
to Alex Jones lawyer. It's just a coincidence.
But then sometimes you start to see coincidence
after coincidence, and it starts to really not
seem like a coincidence. And indeed, it is now
hard to believe that there is anything short
of a concerted effort to cover up elements of the
January six Trump riot planning and communications
and involvement of all sorts of different parties
in and around the Trump administration. What am
I talking about? Well, here is the latest
news. January 6th, text messages were wiped
from phones of key Trump Pentagon officials.
It is starting to be very difficult to believe
that these are mere benign coincidences.
Texts were deleted. They were transitioning
to new devices at exactly this time. After
being told to preserve the text messages,
the D.O.D. wiped phones, all of the same group
of people and of specifically at a time and
related to January 6th. It's hard to believe
in this number of coincidences. Let's look at
what CNN reports. The Defense Department wiped
the phones, wiped and flushed gates, the phones
of top departing DOD and Army officials at the
end of the Trump administration deleting any key
texts from key witnesses to events surrounding
the January 6th attack on the U.S. Capitol.
The acknowledgment that the phones from the
Pentagon officials had been wiped was first
revealed in a foil lawsuit. American oversight
brought against the Defense Department and Army.
The watchdog group seeks January six records from
former Acting Secretary of Defense Chris Miller,
former chief of Staff Kash Patel, former Secretary
of the Army Ryan McCarthy and other prominent
Pentagon officials. Miller Patel and McCarthy
have all been viewed as crucial witnesses for
understanding the government response to the riots
and former President Trump's reaction. All three
were involved in the Defense Department's
response to sending National Guard troops
to the Capitol as the riot was unfolding. There
is no suggestion that the officials themselves
erased the records. Oh, boy, oh, boy. Everyone
involved who committed a crime should be in jail
or prison. I'm not saying imprison people
without due process and without finding
them guilty. That's not what I'm saying.
I'm saying that there should be no exempt
exemptions here because of people's roles,
whether it be in DOD or wherever the case may be.
Every day criminals get in trouble all the time
for destroying evidence. White collar criminals.
Often when it comes to tampering with
or destruction of evidence, end up in a
situation where prosecutors go where it's really
hard to prove that they acted intentionally.
Going to be very difficult to prove state
of mind here. And yet we know it's not
that difficult because everyday criminals,
street criminals, as they're sometimes called,
get in trouble regularly for these exact same
things. And there are just too many coincidences
here to believe that this was not some kind
of concerted effort. Now, you might recall
that days before what was ultimately the final
the last and final January six committee hearing,
there was the idea that on a beautiful Tuesday,
the House committee was going to get recovered
text messages from these tranches of text messages
that were deleted and hours before the deadline,
the revelation was not recoverable. Not going
to get them. Sorry. And every aspect of this
raises questions as to in which organizations were
their foot soldiers, for lack of a better term,
for the Trump riot cover up. Now, we can't say
that secret. So part of this is related to Secret
Service here. We're talking about DOD. I'm not
ready to say Secret Service was involved, but the
longer it goes, it starts to get weird because
on the one hand, we have Secret Service agents
who supposedly said in the aftermath of Cassidy
Hutchinson's devastating testimony about what
happened on January 6th, we're willing to
come in and testify under oath about all
the lies Cassidy Hutchinson was telling. And I
said at the time, Well, great, got them under
oath. But then we'll have competing under oath
statements. Until then, all we have is nonsense.
And then they never testified, and the House
committee was welcoming them with open arms
and they never testified. That starts to get a
little bit weird. Then we hear it. Well, the text
messages involving the Secret Service also aren't
recoverable. We can't give you anything. Sorry.
Okay. It starts to get a little weird. Now
we find out that the DOD was wiping phones,
starting to get even weirder. So I'm not
pretending to have an answer. I'm not positing
any particular allegation of a conspiracy. I'm
merely saying there's too many coincidences here
to believe that this is merely a coincidence. And
there seem to be actors in multiple organizations,
at multiple agencies and multiple levels of
this who don't seem to be forthcoming in the
way that you would imagine and that you would hope
government officials would be. That's where I will
leave it. And the speculation can sort of go from
there. If you have an idea as to what you believe
took place here. Find me on Twitter at David
Pakman and let me know who was involved and to
what extent. The David Pakman Show is a community,
viewer and audience supported program. I encourage
you to sign up on my website. Join Pacman dot
com. We do lots of great things for our members,
including a daily bonus show now available in
three ways one on a website for members only too,
and an RSS feed that you can put into any
podcasting app that you have or three delivered
to you hot off the presses via email hours before
the show is publicly available to everybody else.
Sign up at join Packman dot com. You can use the
coupon code Obamneycare. Where is my Obamneycare?
Oh my goodness. I don't even have it.
Speaker 4: Nuclear proliferation.
Speaker 1: That's not it. Okay. Obama. Obama
is the coupon code that you can use to get a
discount off of the cost of your membership.
Do the thing, folks. It's a beautiful thing.